death stranding is an upcoming game from
Metal Gear Solid mastermind Hideo Kojima
his first since his dramatic breakup
with Konami a couple years back if
you've seen the trailers you know it
starts The Walking Dead's Norman Reedus
rogue ones mas Mickelson and visionary
director Guillermo del Toro
we know from interviews that the game
takes place in an open-world setting and
will have some kind of multiplayer
component in addition to a lengthy
single-player campaign and yet when it
comes to specifics Kojima plays things
close to the vest
death stranding looks like it's going to
be an unusual experience in Kojima is
doing everything he can to keep the
mystery alive until the games as yet
unknown release date still occasionally
a few details slip through for example
whaletail death stranding is all about
connections and maybe a little bit about
whales in a typically mysterious
interview with Wired Kojima said that
the story is about what you call strands
in psychology how people are connected
Kojima says death stranding involves
connecting players to one another via
gameplay and explores Kojima's ideas
about trying to connect one character to
another or to connect life and death the
title also might have something to do
with whales the first trailer opens on a
beach full of dead wildlife including
dead whales when whales beach themselves
marine biologists call it stranding
experts think the giant creatures may do
it to escape predators or they may just
be lost but it rarely ends well the
whales typically die of dehydration or
die when the high tide comes in what all
this has to do with the story of death
stranding however remains a mystery
anime inspiration clearly Kojima has
1988 anime classic Akira on the brain
when fans asked when death stranding is
going to come out Kojima Productions
replied on Twitter before the Tokyo
Olympic Games before the new Akira the
Tokyo Olympics are in 2020 but the Akira
reference isn't as clear Warner Brothers
has been trying to get a live-action
Akira film off the ground for years but
the movie isn't officially in production
and has no definite release date so it
could just be a joke but it might also
be a clue yeah yeah
don't make me laugh it's a bit of a
stretch but some fans think they found
accurate connections in death strandings
two trailers as well
the chunky tank from the second trailer
looks vaguely like the tanks in akira
and like Akira death stranding looks
like it's set in a world ravaged by
nuclear war and clearly has something to
do with human experimentation game
changer we know at a very basic level
that death stranding is going to be an
action title and that it won't be a
horror game like Kojima's cancelled
collaboration with Rita san del Toro
silent Hills beyond that what players
actually do in the game is still unknown
but Kojima hints that he's trying to
create a new genre or at least sub-genre
talking to Digital Spy in June 2016
Kojima says people only called the
original Metal Gear a stealth game years
later once the industry realized it
needed a name to describe the game's
inspired by it
Kojima says death stranding is a similar
case telling Digital Spy the player will
be controlling Norman but by playing it
they will find something different
something that won't fit in establish
terms referencing a Japanese story
Kojima uses a rope in to stick as
metaphor saying early humans used the
stick to keep away bad things while the
ropes purpose was to keep good things
close currently most video games focus
on the stick punches kicks guns and
other forms of aggression with death
stranding Kojima wants to make a game
with a lot more rope metaphorically
speaking but it's still unclear how that
idea will translate to actual gameplay
baby boom for some reason death
strandings promotional materials are
chock-full of babies and baby dolls in
the first trailer Norman Reedus picks up
a lost baby on a beach cradling it to
his body before it disappears in the
second guillermo del toro cradles a
womb-like capsule with a living baby
inside while a mangled doll floats at
his feet kojima productions film both
trailers using motion capture technology
and didn't use real babies in the
production of either video on set dolls
stood in for the infant's in a series of
tweets Kojima revealed that the prop
baby held by Norman Reedus is named Lugh
number two the other baby doll used is
named Lugh number one it's unclear if
the name loo has any significance
whatsoever but when the details are this
scarce we'll take what we can get engine
twins
2017 s open-world sci fi smash horizon
zero dawn set a new very high bar for
video game graphics thanks largely to
guerrilla games proprietary décima
engine
so it's no surprise that Kojima wanted
to use decima to bring death stranding
to life instead of signing a contract or
demanding a fee however gorilla gave
Kojima access to the engine for free so
if you enjoyed the look and feel of
horizon zero dawn expect death stranding
to have a similar feel but with a Kojima
twist there is one catch to this
arrangement but it's more like a bonus
any changes that Kojima makes to the
decima engines code has to be shared
with gorilla allowing both companies to
develop it together
according to Kojima it's a deal that's
worked out beautifully after six months
he says the code completely merged
together into something new and improved
at PlayStation experience 2016 Kojima
through a translator said gorillas
ambition is extraordinary making game
Cena ways like going to space and you
know Gary Locke came I was like well
let's go to Jupiter together so that's a
great feeling
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]